hello we're glad you've joined us for
this light webinar managing genetically
modified rodent strains focus on
genotype and genetic background I am
Christina mahalik of lab routes and I'll
be moderating today's session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
Lavery's the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning to
learn more visit lab roots dot-com I
hope you announce this for we begin
today you can post questions to the
speaker during this presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you click on the green
kill me button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the screen lastly this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits now it is my
pleasure to present today's speaker dr.
Steve Fire and PhD professor of
microbiology in immunology and genetics
Geisel School of Medicine at Dartmouth
dr. fearin received his Bachelor of
Science from the University and
in 1975 and his doctorate from Stanford
in 1990 after postdoctoral work as an
NIH research fellow in research
associate at the Fred Hutchinson Cancer
Research Center dr. firing joined the
faculty of the department of
microbiology at Dartmouth Medical School
in 1997 at that time he established a
transgenic animal production facility at
Dartmouth and this has become the
current mouse modeling shared resource
which provides an extensive line of
services around generation analysis
utilization and genetically modified
mice dr. firing will now begin his
presentation the floor is yours hello hi
it's it's a pleasure to be with you all
and to discuss the topic of handling
genetically modified animals thank you
for the introduction Christina so here's
a brief overview first we'll just go
through some basic ideas about
transgenesis and mice we're only talking
about research because that's the only
thing anybody would like to do with a
transgenic Mouse unlike some other
transgenic animals which could
potentially be used for other purposes
we're going to touch on the new ideas of
rigor and reproducibility that are being
brought out of the NIH their
expectations and how the handling of
transgenic mice might be affected by it
we'll discuss the types of genetic
modifications and in particular the
challenges of genotyping because as you
can see from the title I think that the
genotyping ends up being the biggest
overall challenge and I know that many
of you are our lab animal veterinarians
and you're really not responsible for
the genotyping but I think it's
important for you understand the
challenge because that's where people
are going to get into problems with
their Genet
animals then we're going to discuss the
importance of genetic background and
away a convenient way to check it and
then a few general husbandry issues that
might be useful to think about
transgenesis
is the stable transfer of genetic
material from one organism to another by
non-sexual means well we've been doing
it since the 80s it's been done in all
sorts of vertebrates as well as lots of
lower animals and it's a standard
technique in in research and as many of
you know there are genetically modified
organisms particularly plants that are
out in the environment and being used
every day as a food so this is a basic
technology that's pretty
well-established so why are we even
interested in transgenic mice the most
common reason is that we want them to
help us study human disease do they
enable us to manipulate the genome and
make genetic changes that tell us
something about that progression of the
disease
they give us models to test new
therapies and they help us understand
the basic biochemical and genetic
pathways that are involved in the
disease so if you think in general about
genetics one of the ways I like to help
people understand genetics is the idea
behind genetics is generally that we
would break a single part of the Machine
to try to understand how the Machine
functions you have a mutant you study
the phenotype and that's how the Machine
of how you can understand the Machine
now classic genetics has called forward
genetics in which an investigator would
recognize an organism with a particular
phenotype or select for that phenotype
and then they would try to go from that
phenotype and identify the genetic cause
so that's forward genetics from
phenotype to genotype with trans
genex we're talking about reverse
genetics in which we make a particular
genetic change and then we analyze the
phenotype so we know what the genetic
change is and our questions are what
will the phenotype be geneticists
consider two basic classes of genetic
changes one would be a gain of function
so you bring in something new and then
the transgenics this might be when you
introduce a trans gene that's going to
over express a new protein or express a
modified protein or you can have a loss
of function in which you manipulate the
genes in order to reduce or eliminate
expression of a particular gene now the
ultimate goal of all this sort of
manipulation would be to be able to turn
on or off any gene in any specific type
of cell at any time during the life of
the mouse I'm not going to go into great
detail about the tools that are
available but it's an idea that I want
you to see is that the key to doing any
of that is a promoter that drives the
genes specifically in a particular type
of cell now that could be a randomly
integrated promoter or often these days
with because we have a lot of control we
use an endogenous promoter in order to
recognize that the the the endogenous
gene is controlled appropriately and the
that gives us our promoter specificity
so these are the base
this is a diagram of the basic gene
alterations so if we look on the left we
might do a gene replacement in which we
have a targeted system in which we can
go into the genome and make a specific
change in a targeted region and we might
change the gene that's in that location
and in the vernacular it's called a
knockin and we would lose expression of
the normal gene that was there because
we've replaced it with something else we
can do a knockout
in which we target a gene and basically
make a change so that it no longer
functions and we can do a gene addition
in which is we bring in another copy of
the gene a modified copy of the gene but
we're not manipulating the endogenous
gene there dot there may not even be an
endogenous gene right so that's sort of
a classic transgenic once again the more
control the better and we would like to
be able to do any of these things so
that they get expressed specifically
when we want to do them in the specific
cell or tissue of interest but we won't
go too deeply into that now there are a
lot of systems of genetics and they're
cheaper and easier to use than mice but
we use mice because often particularly
in biomedical research certain systems
are only available in a vertebrate and
the genetically modified vertebrate of
most research interest is the mouse it's
got the most highly developed systems
it's the cheapest to house the easiest
to use people also obviously use cell
lines and they're good but it's not the
whole organism and generally the cell
lines have a lot of abnormal
characteristics and they're not
interacting with anything else in this
relationship mice have a normal
development normal physiology Mouse
studies tend to be very definitive if
you demonstrate something in a
transgenic Mouse then generally that
proves it
within a mouse that that's how the
system works and that's really a very
valuable one limitation is that there's
often redundancy so you may manipulate a
gene and not see a phenotype for
instance and the reason might be there's
another gene which is taking on the same
function or already has the same
function doesn't mean that the original
gene is not functional it just means
that it's not showing up with a
recognizable phenotype so now we'll
discuss a bit of what's commonly been
referred to as rigor and reproducibility
this is a big concept being pushed out
of the NIH review panels are being
expected to assess the recognition of
rigor and reproducibility by the
applicants journals are being asked to
look at this all across the scientific
world there's more and more of demand
that biological experiments can be
replicated and within that there's an
expectation that biological reagents
will be validated so as many of us know
we use reagents we get them from other
people we're told what they are but it
is going to be more and more of a demand
that if you're going to publish it or
put it into a grant you mean you need to
have validated that this is what you
think it is and it will in fact you can
show that with some data some of the
classic examples are people do a bunch
of studies with cell lines and human
cell lines and people have found that
many of what people thought was cell on
a was actually a different cell line
often HeLa just because he'll is around
the labs and if it gets into somebody's
culture it can take over so that's an
example so for a genetically modified
animal this means that the modification
must be clearly described and how the
animals are determined to how that
modification must be clearly stated so
how are they genotype and the second
idea is that the genetic back
the animal should be stated and
potentially validated and we'll get into
that more later and these are raising
the bar for what's expected for
reporting on transgenic animal
experiments so now as I mentioned I have
20 years specifically running a facility
that makes genetically modified animals
and generally we get the construct from
the client we put it into the mice and
we ask the clients to genotype them we
don't do the genotyping and believe me
the genotyping is prone to problems we
could talk about why that might be the
one obvious reason is that every lab is
underfunded people are under pressure to
get more done with less corners are cut
and the other aspect is that in academic
labs people are in constant flux and so
when a postdoc or a graduate student
leaves they might leave a protocol
behind about how this genotype is done
how these mice are genotype but it may
not get done so well by the next person
and in general validation is not in a
high priority mistakes and genotyping
occur they get propagated they disrupt
the experiments and often if it's
significant that can show up and you
could say well that Mouse did not act at
all the way it's supposed to we better
check it but there may be subtle effects
that are not so easy they could get
propagated through the experiment and
cause problems so genotyping is a
problem it's a challenge it's it's
essential so how do we do it well the
first thing is you got to have a solid
and practical assay for both the genetic
modification and the background strand
contribution we'll talk more about
background strain but essentially most
often transgenic mice are made in a
either a mixed inbred strain or specific
inbred strain but for various technical
and experiment
reasons people want them in a different
background screen so they will do back
crossing in which they read them into
the new strain they genotype them to
make sure they have the mutation and
they do it again
so analyzing all this and keeping it
straight requires careful applications
of the genotyping assays and good
record-keeping just to make sure that
you know what your animals are and the
background strain has rarely been
checked but there are new technologies
that make it relatively easy and
inexpensive to do that and we'll talk
about them so the earliest basic
transgenics were gain-of-function
transgenics in which a DNA solution was
injected into the pro-- nucleus of a
zygote on the morning after
fertilization and that DNA at some
frequency gets integrated randomly into
the genome and often in multiple copies
and the offspring are screened for the
presence of that DNA this is the sort of
construct it would be there would be a
promoter as you can see on the left and
gold and that's going to control the
expression there's going to be a trans
gene and that's going to be the the
payload so how does the integration
occur well first of all it's not
homologous integration there's nothing
about the genome that recognizes this
transgene so it goes in randomly we
don't know where it is and that's going
to be important for the genotyping
generally it goes in with multiple
copies at a given site often it'll be
one site most of the injected oocytes or
zygotes are not transgenic at all and
they're often in head to tail
orientation but it can be in multiple
sites often there's other rearrangements
at the integration site so it's not
simply a nice clean and
certian there's often deletions
inversions other things that happened at
that site now there are retroviruses
that people have used for transgenesis
and they can infect the Oh a site this
gives a single copy at each site it's
very efficient but the problem has been
that retroviruses get shut down by
machinery which recognizes them early in
development and it's really not a very
commonly used technique lentiviruses or
retroviruses not for doing a germline
transgenic so how would we do genotype a
DNA injection transgenic and it's always
done with PCR so you develop a PCR
that's recognized as a unique sequence
in the trans gene it's not that hard to
do and you apply it to the animals one
of the problems is usually you validate
it using the same trans gene and you
might use high concentrations of that
but when you go to genotype the
offspring particularly the founders to
identify the ones that have it it's
going to be in a lot lower frequency
because it's only a few copies in the
whole genome and so what may be able to
recognize an anagram of pure DNA quite
nicely is not able to recognize a single
copy in 59a grams of genomic DNA so
that's the first problem the second
problem is that trans genes are referred
to generally as hemizygous meaning
there's some place in the genome they're
only on one of the two alleles so it's
hard to identify them as homozygous
because you can't recognize anything
other than the presence of the trans
gene in order to make a line in which a
trans gene is homozygous the most common
way to do it this gets into a breeding
issue is to breathe the potential
homozygous first you start by trance by
it by breeding heterozygous offspring
and until you get ones that you think
may be
and then you breed them to a wild-type
offspring if all of the wild-type
offspring have the trans gene then you
likely had a homozygous breeder I know
that's a little bit complicated but
basically you're basically testing it by
a test cross if you get five mice in the
litter when you breed you're potentially
homozygous Mouse to a wild-type Mouse
every mice has the trans gene the
chances are good then your wild-type is
homozygous it's statistical it may not
be true but it's probably a good guess
if you got 15 offspring from that animal
and they all had the trans gene now the
the the ability to be pretty sure that
it's a homozygous animal is growing up
generally you're going to want to do
this with males so that you can actually
breed with lots of females and get a lot
of pups to test okay so now we're going
to go on to what was the next big
technical breakthrough which is gene
targeting where you could actually
manipulate a specific site in the genome
rather than random insertion and this
was done in embryonic stem cells
theoretically we said the goal is to be
able to make any change in any cell and
get it expressed at any time during
development in the mouse so with gene
targeting we're basically able to
theoretically change any bat base in a
three billion base genome which is a
pretty stunning statement and really is
the ultimate in reverse genetics so this
is a quick diagram of how that's done
basically this would be the way you want
to make a knockout so if you look at the
top that's a diagram on the locus of the
locus and we want to delete the area
that's in black in the middle is a
diagram of the construct you have the
two blue regions that are homology
have that empty space which is the
missing sequence and you have a positive
selection which is often neo a drug
selection so you can at least select for
the es cells that have integrated your
construct the bottom is what the
targeted look locus would look like you
would have the two right arms of
homology you'd have the neo there but
the black sequence is gone the genome
recognizes the homology the the
molecular machinery in the genome
recognizes the homology and it crosses
over on each side the right arm crosses
over the left arm crosses over it
replaces what's in the endogenous locus
this is another so so the way these have
been traditionally screened is a
southern blot unfortunately the southern
bot art is a fading art but I'll explain
it so you'll understand how it was done
and how it should be done today there
are other options but it's still the
best so at the top is the expected Lucas
and let's say you're trying to do a
mutation that's going to take out most
of exon 1 and exon 2 and replace it with
what's in the construct which is Lac
Zinio now if you look at the top you see
a 10 KB bar from A to A so let's say a 2
a is a restriction site and that length
is 10 KB and if you have a probe which
is shown under the under the top line at
the far right as 5 Prime a small blue
bar let's say that's the probe so be in
that restriction site if you were to do
a southern blot and use that probe the
wild-type locus would give you a 10 KB
band but now if you make the targeted
change so now you have what looks like
the bottom line you can see it happens
that you've brought in a new a
restriction site in the bottom line but
targeted allele will now have a 7 KB
band
rather than a 10 KB ban when using that
five-prime probe so it might look
something like this where you're
screening a bunch of ESL clones and you
screen them with a southern blot they
all have the 10k because all have at
least one normal allele and then you see
the ones that are targeted it's
unambiguous there's no way to make a
mistake because if we go back to the
other slide you can see the important
point is that the probe is outside the
homologous region the HR 1 the HR 2 is
what's homologous on the contra that
part could get integrated somewhere
randomly but the probe is outside that
so it will not recognize it it does not
see random integration so you get a nice
clean southern blot with no questions
once you have a targeted Mouse you can
now use a PCR and you validated that yet
it's the right thing in the right
location you can now use a PCR to
genotype it and so this would be the one
way it could be done there's many
different variations but it's all pretty
much the same so if you wanted to say
well I'd like to see if the wild-type is
there so you have PCR probe 1 and PCR
probe 2 now you notice that PCR probe 2
is in the deleted region so it's not
going to recognize anything other than
the wild-type chromosome that doesn't
have the deleted region and now you look
at the targeted chromosome below and
once again you have PCR primer number 1
but now you have a primer that's
uniquely in let's say in this case in
the Neogene it could be a little bit
further over into the region that's been
brought close so now it's going to make
a small band whereas it would otherwise
make a very large band between 1 & 3 I
know that sounds complicated but I hope
you're able to follow and
so you would basically get a PCR blot
that had a 300 base pair of band
whenever you got wild-type and a 350
base pair band whenever you have the
mutants so you could recognize
homozygous wild-type heterozygous for
the mutation homozygous mutant it's a
nice solid screen
so now we'll diverge and we'll talk
about CRISPR caste 9 most of you I
expected heard about CRISPR and caste 9
basically it's a more efficient way of
targeting and making the homologous
recombination so I showed you how a ESL
homologous recombination has been done
in the past this is a technical
improvement and it's a technical
improvement because of one reality which
is if there's a double strand cut at the
site at which you want to make a change
at the target site it increases the
potential for homologous change or for a
random mutation there hundred to a
thousand fold
so you may not need to have a selectable
marker you may be able to do it directly
in a mouse zài go and that's what people
are working on and that often works the
key is the cut at the site what's really
useful about CRISPR is not only that it
makes a cut at a target site but that
target site is set up by a small RNA
right the easiest thing to do with
CRISPR is what's noted in the bottom
line which is the cut often is
associated with deficient repair
something gets scrambled some of the
bases are deleted and as you know if you
delete anything other than a something
that is a factor of 3
you've caused a train a frameshift if
it's in the coding region and you could
pretty much kill the gene with that so
that's happening with crisper
here's a diagram where we talk about the
guide RNA that's what makes it really
efficient all of the CRISPR protein the
Cassadine protein is always the same but
you can target it to different places
with a different guide RNA so you can
make very easily and simply different
targeted mutations in fact you can make
libraries of these in cell lines so we
show on the left of two possibilities
the one we show below it the one on the
left is the most commonly used one is
the most efficient where basically
you're making the cut the repair is
deficient and you get a mutation you
have no idea what that mutation is and
it's hard to find and we'll talk about
that in a minute
on the right is something where you make
the cut but you also bring in a repair
template something that has homology
that will be recognized as homology and
will hopefully make the changes that are
targeted in the same way they are
targeted in the S cells this will work
it's not nearly as efficient so okay so
before I get out of that I'd like to go
back to this the problem with especially
the situation on the left is that you
really have no idea what the mutation is
you may have taken out a few bases you
may have a beautiful frame ship but you
don't know what it is and there's really
no way the genotype it other than by
sequencing and remember in the same
tissue sample if you have the tail cut
or something you're gonna have lots of
wild-type as well so you're sequencing
trying to see a mutation where at best
half the alleles are wild-type so when
you sequence it you're going to kind of
get something where it's like well it
looks like and my cut side I'm not
getting a real clean read so that's kind
of tricky that's some tricky molecular
biology
[Music]
it's not so easy to do and lots of
people are trying to do it and I'm sure
there's a lot of good founders that are
being missed because they were not well
genotyped so now we'll switch a bit to a
topic of the genome and scanning the
genome as I'm sure you all know there
are many inbred strains and the reason
that there's many strains is because
they really are different the genetic
background of the inbred strains in
particular make a major difference in
the phenotype of a given genetic
modification the genetic modification
made in one background is often needed
in a different background in order to do
an experiment so background matters I
can't emphasize this too much it's been
seen again and again a particular
phenotype in one background may have a
very different or no visible phenotype
in a different genetic background either
mixed or inbred so background matters to
the outcome of the experiment and people
started seeing that when different labs
were making targeted mutations and then
seeing essentially similar mutations had
different phenotypes and it turned out a
lot of that was the background okay so
if you're going to breed a transgenic
modification into another background the
traditional way that was done is you
took a mouse that was heterozygous for
you mutation you put it in with a wild
type of the strain that you wanted to
move it into and then you select the
offspring that have the mutation and you
do that again at least ten times and
statistically that gives you a very high
probability that your mutation is there
on a very small region of the genome
that's derived from the original strain
and that's called a congenic people
recognize that if you could scan the
genome you could make those changes a
lot faster by finding the mice that by
random reassortment have a higher
contribution from the strain you're
trying to move into so like in any sort
of a breeding like that there's going to
be a bell-shaped curve of how much
contribution from which strain in in the
original trans gene derived parents and
some are going to have more from the
target strain and less from the original
strain
if you can select those you can then
move the whole process faster by
identifying essentially the mice that
have a genotype closer to the one you
want and you could basically cut it in
half and that's known as speed con genex
so I'm going to focus on what I think is
the best system and it's a system we
actually developed here in which we can
scan the entire genome there are a
variety of systems people use I'll
explain to you why I think this is the
best it's basically a speed con genic
system it enables us to scan over 5,000
snips that are either A or B there's
only two options for each snip and then
we they've been mapped to all the
different inbred strains so in any
different combination of inbred strains
usually there's two to three thousand of
these snips that will be informative
there will be a in one strain and being
the other so we can look at that region
and see is that a a a B or B B is it
homozygous one strain homozygous the
other strain or heterozygous that can be
used for the speed congenic that i've
talked about can also be used for a
background check and i think that's very
important because as there's going to be
more and more demand to make sure that
the background of the transgenic mouse
used for experimental purposes is what
you think it is there's
to be more demand for this and so this
is a way in which by simply sending a
tail snip to dark Mouse they can do that
and give you a map of the whole genome
and basically validate for you whether
there is anything other than the region
that you expect to become genic which is
coming from the original trans gene
extreme it can also be used for
genome-wide Association studies that's
kind of a different topic I won't get
into it we think it's relatively
inexpensive it's $149 per genome and we
think it's a really valuable and I'll
show you what kind of data you get out
of it and it's very nice for the
investigator because basically they take
some tail clips and send it to dark
Mouse which is here at Dartmouth and we
send them back this type of data so
here's an example on the far left is the
strain that is being bred into it's
being bred into c57 black 6 so when we
take a control mouse the whole genome
has that color it's all black 6 all the
snips are black 6 on the phone right is
the mass that it came from which is a
one to nine Mouse so that's going to be
orange and once again when we have a
control mouse we're going to see that
all of the snips are from the 1 to 9
months and now in this example we're
looking at three different now mice and
as you can see they each have a
different proportion close but different
proportion of the black 6 background
with the one on the Left 162 having 98%
the highest among the 3 and the one on
the right
having 94% the lowest among the 3 so if
you were to say okay I'm doing speed con
genex I want to pick 162 TT rwf 162
higher proportion I've already moved in
half the distance between 94% and 100%
I'm halfway there so I've already cut
out a generation what we give you is
something that gives you a detailed
you like this so this is the chromosomal
scan of those mice each of the
chromosomes 1 through 20 20 and 21 are
the X and y chromosomes and so you can
see by the colors that they are mostly
green but they have regions of purple
which we know are heterozygous so let's
first look at the graph on the right
where we're looking at 162 which is the
better Mouse I've circled the region
where the transgene is we know that's
where the targeted mutation is you see
it's a reasonably small region from
chromosome 11 we have one other region
of contamination of the original
chromosomal background the original
genetic background that's on chromosome
12 and you see it as purple now let's
look at 162 it's got the region on
chromosome 11 where the transgene is
it's got the region on chromosome 12
which is also found in 162 but 161 has
two other actually three other regions
it's got a double region on chromosome
one and then another region of the
original strain on chromosome 14 so you
clearly see where every part of the
genome comes from it's easy to
understand and you immediately
understand what's going on this is a
simple example we screen a lot of mice
that have 2 & 3 transgenes but as you
can see it's a valuable way of getting a
snapshot of the mice that you're going
to use for breeders to generate your
experimental animals there are even
animals that were used in an experiment
ok so one of the ideas of us as
experimentation gets more and more
complex it's much easier to handle the
breeding
if everybody's homozygous so
homozygosity is the goal but sometimes
it's not possible it causes problems
they may be non viable they may have
reduced fertility there may be other
problems with making a homozygous animal
they may be poor breeders you may be
able to use them for experiments but
they don't live that long so in other
words you would have to say well that
has to be heterozygous if there's no
choice you've got to make it
heterozygous so you have to have some
complex breeding strategies if you have
a mice that need to homozygous knockouts
in transgene you you may have no choice
but to breed the homozygous even if they
have poor health every time you have to
move away from the homozygous when you
have to have and then you reduce your
yield you lose half of your potential
pups as usable offspring it's a little
bit complicated but that's basically the
idea so now we're going to go to the
last topic some general husbandry so
transgenic animals can have problems the
genetic modifications impact their
health and therefore they impact the
husbandry
many of them are immunodeficient well
most of the people who are handling our
facilities are quite skilled at handling
immunization animals low fertility is is
a problem poor ability to nurture pups
short lifespan they get pathology all
these things have to be taken into
account to maintain this strain and each
one of them has to be considered I don't
think they're all that complicated but
they're just things you have to be aware
of often there's problems in in in
getting litters and there's problems in
taking care of the litters one thing
that many people already do is it's good
to have high-fat Chow for breeders and
there have been certain
Janak animals a particular one that
we've worked with is the non-skid aisle
to gammon knockout mice which are very
commonly used immunodeficient mice and
they breed significantly better with
high fat child in with regular chow
so remember to give them breeder Chow
often there's poor mothering they don't
feed the mice you can have timed mating
of transgenic and wild-type mouse that
could be housed together so they're
giving birth at the same time oh you
could do that similarly and then
transfer the pups to the foster mother
so it's more work but you generally have
to have a wild type Mouse is going to
nurture these foster pups often there's
low fertility in one sex the other sex
may be fertile well sometimes if it's
the problem is in the homozygous then
you have to work with the homozygous of
one sex a heterozygous or the other
you're losing half your pups are not
going to be homozygous but at least
you're getting some breeding and so
without going into a lot of detail I
just bring up that idea that you got it
you got to handle each one of them
differently and you got to think about
where you are that's the end of the
presentation and I think we're going
back to the moderator to discuss some
questions well I guess thank you doctor
firing for that informative presentation
a quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them in
the Q&A box found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window
dr. firing will answer as many questions
as time permits
dr. firing let's see why our first
question asks why is a cell tissue
specific promoter
the key to making controlled genetic
modifications thank you Christina it's
the key reagent because once you can get
cell type or tissue specific expression
there's a lot of genetic tricks that can
be used there's things that you can use
that will make a tranche in inducible or
will specifically turn it on or turn it
off
there's Cree which can be used to make a
secondary genetic modification only in
cells that Express the Cree so if you
have control about which cells Express
the Cree or when during development if
you can put it on an inducible promoter
you can manipulate that with Cree so
there's lots of genetic tools but they
all demand one thing which is tissue
specific controlled expression which
comes from a tissue specific promoter
either through a knock in into an
endogenous promoter or through a clone
promoter that is shown to be tissue
specific and regulatable in a particular
cell type or at a particular time during
development thank you Christina we'll go
back to you
excellent thank you so much our second
question today asks we have animals that
Express Cree in specific tissues in our
colony how can that be used to make
novel genetically modified mice thank
you Christina so one of the powerful
technical developments has been the use
of cream as a genetic tool basically
crea does one thing it recognizes its
short recognition sites which are called
loxp sites and it recombines there now
if you have something in between those
loxp sites Cree can recognize the site
and will delete whatever is in there so
you could make a cell type-specific
deletion of a particular gene and it's
very efficient it works on both alleles
on almost all cells it's really an
efficient reaction and so you could
bring in Cree either as part of the of
another trans gene or even on a virus
and make specific changes only in the
cells of interest there are ways of
using it to turn on a gain-of-function
it's very flexible and what has
developed is it's really a two part
system so once there's a mouse the
transgenic Mouse that expresses tree
Cree well in a particular tissue or it
has a regulatable Cree that gets turned
on there's some to get turned on when
you when you give tamoxifen to the
animal for instance so you can control
it and it's expressed in the tissue you
then control it with tamoxifen if you
breed that to an animal which has a
region that has the loxp sites which in
the trade is called phlox you can then
specifically make that change so for
example if you have a phlox two wheel
we have one for pi3 kinase we could
bring in a cream ass that expresses Cree
in the liver and we could see what
happens when we delete pi3 kinase in the
liver we could bring in a different
cream mouse that expresses Cree in
t-cells and ask the same question so
rather than making new mice all the time
we take an existing cream mouse that's
already been characterized for Cree
expression greet it to the mass that we
have that has our flocks the we love
interest and in a few generations we
have the experimental mice we need and
are doing the experiment so it's very
rapid people are referring to these as a
cree zoo it's very powerful and you may
have some animals in accra zoo already
in your facilities back to you Kristina
doctor firing thank you so much it looks
like we only have time for one last
question and the last question asks is
the dark mass system usable to compare
any two strings of mice thank you
Christina
so doormouse has its own proprietary
design panel and all of the inbred
strains that we're aware of have been
sequenced we designed the panel to give
maximum coverage to any possible pair of
trend of inbred strains now some of them
have so we said before that there's a
5300 a bee snips they're only they're
only informative meaning there's only a
in one strain and being one strain the
average is about two between two and
three thousand or inbred strains so we
have good coverage on all the inbred
strains we have better coverage on some
than others now all of this was done
with mus musculus we have never used any
of the other mouse strains that some
people interested such as Musca stay
Gnaeus but within mus musculus we're
very confident that we can get good
genomic coverage of all the inbred
combinations where we don't have good
coverage is on the y chromosome and
that's because there simply are not many
snips on the y chromosomes because they
don't recombine so at the tip which is
the pseudo autosomal region that does
recombine with the X there are some
snips but the rest of the Y does not
recombine and so the snips are very very
infrequent and it's really not usable
for analyzing changes at the Y
chromosome fortunately that's a pretty
rare requirement so I thank you all I
believe we're at
the end of our time and it's a pleasure
to give you this presentation I hope
it's been useful doctor firing I would
like once again to thank you so much for
this enjoyable and very informative
presentation before we wrap up the
session do you have any final comments
that you want to leave us with today
thank you Christina no I really don't I
hope that people have become more aware
particularly of the genotyping problem
which is going to cause most of the real
issues and even though that's out of
your control I hope it's the sort of
thing that's in the back of your head
when there's problems with somebody's
transgenic mouse colony don't be afraid
to say well do we think maybe there's
some genotyping issues here and I think
that that might turn out to have been a
good thought thank you I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
thank lot roots for today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through may 2017 lab routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's informative
live presentation this is Christina from
lab routes thank you so much goodbye